round one I'm a Critic and I'm also a
Critic sorry but Chris Pratt is going to
be terrible as Mario Chris Pratt will be
terrible as Mario Jack Black will
probably be good Jack Black is always
good I have hope it still could be good
round two the Mario trailer is looking
not great they barely showed anything
Chris Pratt doesn't sound Italian at all
will I still see it I'm still gonna see
it yeah round three early Critic reviews
are in and it is looking great not good
you know a movie is good when the
audience loves it and the critics you
know a movie has a super toxic fan base
when the audience score is super high
and the critics score is super low yeah
well maybe critics should turn off their
brain sometime here we go just enjoy
things for what they are so I saw the
Mario I saw the Mario movie it was
actually fine fine I mean it had a fun
energy and the Easter eggs were cool
Jack Black was great Jack Black is great
but honestly audiences are but honestly
critics are giving it way too much
praise not giving enough praise look
it's a perfectly fine movie I think
critics are yeah being a little too
harsh it was fun yeah it was fun see we
we agree we agree it's a masterpiece you
just said it was fine well to you fine
means garbage so I'm saying it's a
masterpiece why because this is my thing
now Mario is my thing this makes me want
to hate it even more exactly critics are
haters whatever Mario is the worst movie
ever made